yo sup guys it's Marcus tromelin here
from mkbhd and welcome to another
unboxing and first impressions video
this is going to be the Griffin unboxing
at first impressions video so this was
kind listen out to me by Griffin
technologies and of course their link
will be in the description and I was
just going to be a very general and
boxing and first first impressions of
this product that I unbox here so I'll
get right into it guys here we go this
is the Griffin elevator a laptop stand
unboxing so you can see the box and here
I move this walk down so basically
there's there's actually not very much
else in the package where you can see
here it says elevator very very simple
space-saving laptops in this vid ships
are kind of quickly this is a UPS
package so it was decent timing so let's
just see if we can get into the box
there for our first impressions maybe I
can set it up for you guys on camera
don't need my knife anymore so yeah this
is very very basic um it'll save you no
space on your desk obviously it'll
elevate your laptop and I chose you
actually instructions about what it's
going to look like on the front of it in
case you have no idea you know your body
for the first time but hopefully I can
show you guys in this video what it will
look like so we have a glass piece here
and our to what looks like metal stand
pieces so let's just go ahead and take
the metal stand pieces out one here and
one here the bottom piece says Griffin
XV SS elevator on it and the top piece
is clean and it's just actually made of
solid metal here and a grippy kind of
substance here kind of tacky pretty good
and then we have this this what looks
like a it looks like glass but I do on
something it's plastic and yes it's
light enough to be plastic and it has a
little slots in the left and right hand
side and very grippy material on the
bottom it does say Griffin has Griffin
branding on front why let's just go
ahead and set it up and see you know
first impressions what it looks like and
you can slide a keyboard out of there I
don't know we'll just go ahead and take
a look at it so I'm from a picture it
looks like this will go in the front end
yeah these these two will just slide
right in the left and right hand
so let's just go ahead and do that right
now especially while it's pretty good
fit that's it
yeah pretty good uh there we go so J
going pretty easily this one's taking a
little more effort yeah that works so
yeah that's basically how you set it up
not much effort to it you can see
there's very cool angle going on there
so you'll have this side flat to the
ground and this side will actually be
angled a little bit down to make it
easier for typing now this is not only
for MacBooks
but you can definitely use this for your
PC for your little 15-inch laptop
whatever you may have but turn it over
here you can see a backside it's very
very clean off so I like the fact that
not a whole kind of branding when you
look at it just the Griffin logo up
front here um but overall it's very very
clean very nice looking I do like the
add the simplicity of it so again if you
want to go check this out this you just
hear unboxing and first impressions
video I've got it set up already I'll
put my laptop on this test it out right
now I'm using the NZXT cryo LX over
there um well yeah I'll definitely get
back to you guys with a full review
video on it looks pretty neat to me
anyway this is in Marcus brown a year
from mkbhd I hope you liked this
unboxing video and thanks for watching
peace